good morning hank it's tuesday the first
thing to know is that it's going to take
a while
if you rush you can maybe sign 700
sheets an hour but you're not a machine
which is one of the primary lessons of
this endeavor
ultimately when you account for the time
spent sorting and collecting the paper
and changing pens and so on
it takes around two hours to sign a
thousand sheets
so this will take 300 hours plan
accordingly
then there's the physical aspect of it
hold the marker loosely
remember what that physical therapist
told you once the sharpie is doing the
work
not your hand keep your shoulder relaxed
and don't hold tension in your neck
occasionally you'll want to draw a
spiral to mix up the motions your hand
is making or else right dftba
these little variations are important in
keeping your hand from cramping too much
but the real question is not what your
hand will do for these 300 hours
but what your mind will do what will you
think about
sometimes you'll listen to podcasts or
an audiobook
like back in 2011 when you signed the
first printing of the fault in our stars
you listened to moby dick
now you're enjoying hillary mantel's
trilogy about thomas cromwell
but much of the time you won't listen to
anything
you'll just sit there it's good if you
can spend some time thinking about why
you were doing this
it's a way of saying thanks to people
who will read the book for
buying it of course but also for their
attention
the hours they will give to your work
and it's good if you can remind yourself
that you are
absurdly ridiculously lucky to have this
many sheets to sign
you will also think about whether all
this signing is just a publicity stunt
where is the line between wanting to
share your work and
commodifying yourself or your audience
that's something you will think about
and you will think that maybe you were
just doing this
because you enjoy it or at least you
enjoy something about it
of course you'll think as well about the
obvious psychologist-y explanation for
this endeavor
you will remember being nine years old
and winning a writing contest that meant
you could attend the florida young
writers conference of 1987
and you will remember that a very famous
author whose books you loved was the
special guest at this conference
and that you stood in line with
dog-eared paperback copies of his books
only to be told that the very famous
author was only signing new hardcover
books
which you didn't have money to buy and
how horribly you felt
and then you will think about how now
you understand that this very famous
author probably was not nearly as
wealthy as childhood you
imagined him to be and how you
understand now the internal and external
pressure that is on authors to sell
their new books
but still it's not that hard to sign
your name
and you vividly remember being a
heart-sunk nine-year-old
and it is probably not a total
coincidence that your first memory of
authors was of not getting an autograph
and now you sign your name quite a bit
if nothing else
this is a small thing you can do that
might brighten some people's days
what else will you think about sometimes
you'll think about the signatures
themselves
the little imperfections that you can't
seem to rid yourself of
even after all this practice sometimes
you'll think about how many sheets you
have left in this box
and how many boxes you have left but
mostly
you won't think at all on the other side
of monotony
lies a flow state a way of being
that is just being a present tense
that actually feels present
it's the consolation and pleasure of
driving alone
at night or getting lost in a story
you're listening to the sharpie on the
paper
and you are and this is hank
i'll see you on friday
you